we're raising our girls to be perfect
and we're raising our boys to be brave
most girls are taught to avoid risk and
failure they're taught to smile pretty
play it safe get all A's
boys on the other hand are taught to
play rough and by the time they're
adults and whether they're negotiating a
raise or even asking someone out on a
date they're habituated to take risk
after risk they're rewarded for it an HP
report found that men will apply for a
job if they meet only 60 percent of the
qualifications
but women
women will apply only if they meet a
hundred percent The Bravery deficit is
why women are underrepresented in sen in
c-suites and boardrooms in Congress and
pretty much everywhere you look we have
to socialize our girls to be comfortable
with imperfection and we gotta do it now